there aren't many countries that use an
electoral college to determine the heads
of state and easily the most famous
country that does
is the united states sorry vatican firm
second place for you
and america's electoral college has been
to put it mildly somewhat controversial
over its lifetime
which raises the question why does
america have an electoral college where
did it come from and did anyone try to
get rid of it
at the 1787 u.s constitutional
convention the leading citizens of the
united states were trying to hash out a
government
one aspect of this discussion was how a
president would be elected
at first it was to be done by congress
but honestly very few at the convention
were happy with that and so some other
form was needed
the question was how would this
presidential election be carried out
the compromise was that instead of the
president being elected via the popular
voter via congress he would be done so
via electors
these electors were to be leading men
who would be appointed by the state to
cast votes for the president on its
behalf
and the presidential candidate which won
the most of these electors votes would
be victorious
thus most of the time the president was
essentially elected via a popular vote
just with one extra step
so those at the constitutional
convention approved this system for
several reasons
the first was that it was supposed to
act as a protection against populism
partisanism and mob rule the electors
were supposed to vet a presidential
candidate on their policies
they were supposed to prevent someone
from being elected on a platform of
infringing the rights of their fellow
citizens
mostly the rights of the sort of people
at the constitutional convention
who had lots of money and land and so
didn't want the people to vote for
someone who might take it away from them
the second reason was to defend the
voices of smaller states and also to
prevent the union's politics from being
dominated by the growing urban
population at the expense of those that
lived in rural areas
not everyone at the convention liked
this compromise but many such as
alexander hamilton were extremely
pleased with it
so the fundamentals of the electoral
college mostly remained the same
throughout the 19th century
the only major differences being that
more and more states move to a popular
vote to guide the electors and now the
vice president wasn't the elections
runner-up
so establishing a system is not the same
as keeping it and it wasn't long until
it came under pressure and criticism
this really picked up in 1876 when
rutherford b hayes won the election 185
electoral college votes to 184 despite
losing the popular vote which earned him
the nickname rather fraud hayes
criticism of the system began to focus
on the fact that the u.s was much more
democratic now than it was at the
constitutional convention
and that now individual voters being
represented overrode any of the founding
fathers ideas surrounding mob brawl and
all that
after this there were a few further
elections which saw the candidate who
won the popular vote lose the contest
but barring some arguments being
repeated nothing was really done and
frankly little was even attempted
barring some complaining
so why wasn't anything changed well the
answer is fairly simple
to begin elections in which the elector
or college elected someone who didn't
win the popular vote were still very
rare and so most of the time it was seen
as an irrelevance
and the second reason is that to change
or dissolve the electoral raw college
a constitutional amendment would need to
be passed which would require 66
of congress to vote for it alongside 75
percent of states legislatures
which when combined with the first point
of it mostly being a confirmation of the
popular vote throughout history meant
that there was little chance of it being
changed and also good luck getting
two-thirds of congress to agree on
anything
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker the
pastry section
marvin cassow rob waterhouse danny
maloney mo
aaron the white james castaneda jordan
longley marcus
arsenault jerry lambton gustav swan
rasheed ali colin carson coppertone
izzy david silverman spinning three
plates winston cayward spencer lightfoot
maggie paxkowski
matthew shipley anthony beckett
fortunate calf robert wetzel lexi
schwinn and skye chappelle